[Musique]
alors
ce débat nous allons voir par rapport à
youtube est ce que c'est un tournant
pour la vulgarisation scientifique et
donc je vais laisser youtuber se
présenter eux mêmes ajoute comment ce
couple est pas parce qu un mois j'ai en
fait de chaises comme c'est pour ça
qu'il ya un plus c'est pas l'autre de la
tronche en biais plus de seebach espagne
on achète ce serait pas très intéressant
en pente raide en câbles à la tronche en
biais c'est michel que je vais laisser
mon acte présenté et le séparer c'est
une chaîne dans laquelle j'en fais de la
musique et de la vulgarisation
musicologique qui est une source
bonjour à tous je m'appelle et j'ai une
chaîne et un blog qui s'appelle sciences
de comptoir avec des amis s'appellent
morgan du maine et est ce que le micro
marche d'accord non c'est toujours moins
sport et du coup je parle de d'actu
scientifiques et de sciences en général
un peu tous domaines confondus de la
biologie la géologie de l'astronomie un
peu toi avec des blagues pas de rage est
une chose intéressante c'est tellement
voilà donc moi c'est
c'est un an dax directement de la 300
billets j'ai orienté esprit critique
démarche implique et éthiques
pour quand on voit des trucs bizarres
avec le truc qui s'appelle l'état passe
à côté maquis il présent parce qu'il
partait le monde
bonjour à tous je m'appelle gildas
estime chaîne s'appelle mister jo
politique souveraine je vulgarise donc
des juges et de géopolitique etc on va
dire que c'est un peu comme l'émission
dessous des cartes qui passait sur arte
qui est un peu remis au goût du jour à
la sauce youtube et bien voilà après
cette présentation donc on va
directement commencer par ce petit débat
avec cette première question y at-il en
avant et après youtube en vulgarisation
scientifique basse et réponses courtes
world of d'accord pour le métier de
médiateurs des sciences ça existe depuis
les temps ont changé pas d'historique en
tête et je crois qu'aucun de nous
mais faisait à vendre des vidéos de la
médiation indique le site / blog
mon oeil et les blogs internet les
règles avant internet nécessairement des
choses nous dans le bac au personnel en
main on n'a pas trop d'expérience 20
avant par les blogs
mais le donc voilà il ya un changement
parce qu'ils n'auraient sans doute pas
ce genre de deux événements juste pour
des blogueurs
en fait on avait un salon soit burger et
7 avril ya un an il y avait plus de gens
de ce côté d'as de la table en face
quasiment donc avec les vidéos vous êtes
un peu plus nombreux parce que tu es là
que ici c'est ça qui change ce qui a
changé en géopolitique avec l'apparition
de youtube on va dire que c'est que la
géopolitique c'est un domaine qui est
quand même vraiment dominé par des
personnes de plus de 60 ans parce que
c'est malheureusement une matière en
fait où on croise énormément d'autres
matières la géographie la politique
l'histoire la sociologie et donc du coup
c'est quelque chose effectivement qu'il
manque beaucoup de connaissances et donc
du coup je pense que c'est quelque chose
qui à rester très universitaire et très
on va dire âgées ce qui a permis youtube
c'est l'apparition de jeunes qui ont osé
se lancer sur le sujet on a par exemple
parlant histoire et dave d'histoire bred
qui ont fait une collab sur la syrie on
a le grand gibier qui est parti en irak
et qui a fait une petite introduction
courte de géopolitique où on va dire que
c'est ça a permis vraiment à des jeunes
en fait de parler du sujet et de le
faire de manière beaucoup plus libre que
les codes d'autrefois d'ailleurs ça pose
aussi des problèmes c'est quand on parle
de géopolitique nous en tant que youtube
heures à des universitaires il trouve
qu'on dénature beaucoup de choses parce
que bien sûr c'est toujours plus
compliqué que ce qu'on explique c'est
toujours beaucoup plu au nom de
subtilité on se prend trop de liberté a
résumé c'est un peu le problème mais je
pense que ça a amené beaucoup de
fraîcheur en fait sur le sujet il ya
plein droit qui du coup sont intéressés
alors que si c'est un mec est un pâté de
70 enfin 170 pages qu avec du texte au
moins de ne pas regarder derrière
juste en passant est ce que tu dis c'est
ce que tu dis c'est un peu une
problématique qui touche en général les
vulgarisateurs qui sont souvent
qualifiés qui sont accusés par pas mal
de chercheurs de simplifier à outrance
le propos est du coup de dénaturer un
peu la science et la recherche et trouve
que c'est assez générales et juste pour
rebondir sur ce que tu disais toi après
je fasse migros effectivement la
vulgarisation ça date pas d'hier vous
prenez l'encyclopédie de diderot
d'alembert c'est aussi de la
vulgarisation
prenez les dictionnaires aussi s'en est
donc ça ça à plusieurs siècles
et effectivement la nouveauté de youtube
c'est peut-être de pouvoir toucher un
public qui est beaucoup plus large grâce
notamment à une plateforme qui est plus
horizontale avec le public nous on en
reparlera plus tard
toi tu de l'éducation le truc qui est
intéressant avec avec le turbo s'il sait
que ça a permis là c'est que ça a permis
la remise en avant deux sujets qui
n'étaient pas forcément hyper connus et
de sujets que donc ils vont ne cherchez
pas je pense un petit peu à toute la
sphère qui va parler un petit peu de
vulgarisation des domaines de l'art
moi moi c'est la musique mais il ya
aussi il ya beaucoup de chaînes comme
comme nacht comprend pour rien regarde
sont tous là et alors on va faire une
affaire d'ailleurs une console à tu
prends la musique qui est ici donc tout
ça c'est des domaines la vulgarisation
de l'art que les gens ne pensaient pas à
chercher avant quand on s'intéressait à
la joconde et qu'on cherche des bucs ont
cherché la joconde c'était pour voir
pouvoir le tableau des personnes qui
vont parler de la joconde qui vont
expliquer historiquement la joconde
comment ça se passe quelles sont les
techniques ont été utilisées là-dessus à
7 le premier réflexe c'est pas d'aller
chercher ça donc
youtube a aussi permis ça et c'est aussi
intéressant parce que youtube on a des
vidéastes qu'on suit qu'on apprécie et
qui m'ont parlé de sujets qui sont
complètement imprévisible et l'étude a
permis justement je crois que c'est ça
qui était intéressant aussi par rapport
à ça d'offrir aux gens des contenus
qu'ils le croyaient pas vouloir entre
guillemets et que kiki et il ya des
découvertes souvent qu'ils sont qui sont
inattendus et concert avec énormément de
plaisir
des vidéastes que je suis je serai
absolument pas attendue à m'intéresser à
ce qu'ils font genre tu quittes
économique ce que je peux que j'aime
vraiment bien attendez pas à
m'intéresser à l'économie que je pense
qu'il ya ça aussi qui est intéressant
c'est que tu crées de la curiosité est
ce que pour vous il ya eu par moments
avec game 6 avec gildas est ce que pour
la partie de fait beaucoup plus
scientifique est ce qu'il n'ya pas eu
une période on va dire où il ya eu ben
c'est pas sorcier lesquels m6 qui sont
venus un peu ouvrir un peu la voix
youtube je pense que la plupart des gens
qui me suivent en profondeur âge céder
un ancien sénateur de l'associé moi même
j'avais bien lui est un gamin on met
dans la continuité parce que la télé
n'offrent plus c'était parce travaux on
a plus des démissions de lui arrive le
galaxy sii fonctionnement est bon mais
500 points intéressant qu'à l'époque
mais peut-être est-ce que je peux être
plus exigeant parce que c'était 15 ans
j'ai plaidé
mais le il me semble que il ya une
demande enfin une attente des gens et la
télévision un noeud n'a jamais fait le
travail qu'elle aurait pu faire la
télévision aurait pu être un média de de
popularisation des savoirs et ça a été
un média commercial youtube ne doit pas
faire et ces termes là oui c'est mon
côté militant ça me fait penser à une
conférence des tiers ça me fait penser à
une conférence détiennent klein où il
disait on va faire une petite expérience
de pensée
on va imaginer qu'on explique aris top
ce qu'est la télé et il va s'imaginer
ben oui c'est magnifique on va pouvoir
partager les savoirs à l'infini
directement et c'est à vous imaginer une
retransmission directe la connaissance
de dieu et 10 à la première partie de
l'expérience de pensée deuxième partie
vous mettez à rester devant les anges de
la télé réalité et vous regardez ce qui
fait sa voix là je voulais juste ça me
faisait penser à ça je vois ça le projet
là la blague
vous allez même pas si loin que ça il ya
50 ans dans le passé vouloir montrer ça
donc j'ai accès à après tout ce qu'il ya
eu mais tu es peut produire de
connaissances et les gens l'utilisent
pour jouer un credit crunch pour vous
régaler des chatons en vidéo pour voir
la télé ou bandeaux un bon les gens je
dirais mon dieu mais on se casse le cul
pour améliorer le monde
moi je vous en fait bon ben ça nous
sommes les héritiers de beaucoup
souffert pour qu'on puisse lorsqu'on ce
qu'on fait mais peut-être qu'on n'est
pas à la hauteur
[Musique]
là tout le monde l'entend pour la menace
alien donc justement par rapport à ce
parallèle entre la tv la vulgarisation
scientifique et atv c'est pas sorcier et
youtube
en fait à quand remonte le vraiment le
début de la vulgarisation scientifique
sur youtube
aussi bien en france europe ou même
petite idée aux états unis hirsch il
faut pas loin en france la vulgarisation
scientifique a commencé avec la chaîne
il expérimente bonne qui avait donc là
c'est sa seconde chaîne en fait au début
ils en avaient commencé une autre
en 2008 il ya eu aussi les vraiment les
précurseurs il y avait donc expérimente
boy axt haulotte non sans cette main
tendue après florence porcel et nos
docteurs qui ont commencé tout ça en
france et enfin en francophonie du coup
puisque maintenant il va aussi y en a au
canada en belgique suisse et un peu
partout et et il ya eu un boom de tout
ça en 2013 il ya vraiment beaucoup de
chefs qui sont créés et là j'ai
l'impression que ça me sert si gisèle en
fait ce qui est assez drôle c'est que
j'ai l'impression quand j'en parle à des
à des camarades des canards à dugarry
thater autour de moi j'ai l'impression
que c'est pas mal pas tant les chaînes
de sciences qui ont lancé les qui ont
lancé le gros boom la vulgarisation mais
plus des chaînes comme en fait plus des
franciscains du zou et d'écrans à des
cons à n'importe quoi à l'époque c'était
atroce tout à fait et le coup c'est
assez drôle de se rendre compte que ces
médias qui était d'équité des médias
interposés hyper politique
visuel et analytique n'est plus sur le
champ des sciences du maine et loire ont
aussi mal inspiré beaucoup les
vulgarisateurs scientifiques parce que
la volonté de diffusion de la science ça
fait un moment on en parlait le blogging
c'est quelque chose qui se pratique
depuis bien avant youtube mais j'ai
vraiment cette impression que qu'ils ont
placé un mètre étalon qui qui qui a
donné envie à des gens qui déjà
popularisé la science le dia oui ça
c'est un métier intéressant ça sert
villa c'est un média avec lequel on peut
toucher du public on peut faire de la
vulgarisation peut parler aux gens en
plus il ya une dimension créatrice qui
était super intéressante et ça fait
qu'on se retrouve avec et
qu'effectivement comme tu dis ça pop
maintenant voilà on se retrouve sur
internet avoir des collectifs qui sont
hyper hyper dense serré comme dans un
ipad tu as vu hyper dense avec
énormément de personnes qui participent
et c'est super bon et je pense qu'il ya
effectivement un grand tournant pour la
vulgarisation scientifique grâce à
youtube organisation scientifique
existait avant qu'on me dise
effectivement c'est justement le
l'indépendance et les femmes ont eu vent
pour les accueils qui parle est
d'habitude c'est toi qu'on entend
d'ailleurs qu'est ce qui t'a et du coup
un autre atout de youtube c'est aussi
l'indépendance le fait que tout le monde
peut être son propre média donc ça c'est
pas mal et j'ai oublié deuxième point il
ya effectivement eu un gros boum sur les
chaînes de vulgarisation mais pas dans
toutes les matières on n'est pas très
nombreux sur la géopolitique et il y en
a d'autres mais il ya des impressions
c'est vraiment les matières
scientifiques
on va dire enfin tension qui
s'enhardissaient très large mais je veux
dire qu'on ce que nous cache le plus
biologie
c'est que vers un peu ouvrir un autre
débat mais mais il ya des matières par
exemple la vulgarisation juridique y en
a pas tant que ça non plus y en a des
très bonnes mais pas tant que ça en
économie on n'a pas tant que ça non plus
je politique on n'est pas si nombreux
donc il ya eu un boum mais pas dans tous
les ballons tous les segments et je suis
sûr qu'elle a d'autres qui sont pas du
tout exploité qui est un quotidien
exploité on sera assez bizarre quand on
n'avait pas anticipé avant quoi tous les
microbes débarqué il ya 2000 code sur la
sécurité informatique qui a explosé et
qui reconnaît qu'il répondait justement
une demande puisque le farsi la vo mais
cette manière là c'est aussi qu'il y
avait une demande d'ailleurs c'est pas
le seul n'a aussi enfin y en a d'autres
qui existent aussi au point c'est donc
justement tu parlais de ses chaînes
youtube qui en plus en plus de succès
que ce soit vrai sécurité ou alors pour
d'autres scientifiques août d'autres
sujets de vulgarisation scientifique
y at il vraiment des stars de la
vulgarisation scientifique
est ce que le succès vraiment justifiée
dans ce domaine si tu es une star tu
peux répondre à leurs politiquement
correct politiquement incorrect enfin
palliant diplomate alors le monde de la
science et la recherche est un monde
dans lequel il n'y a pas d'autorité
normalement donc il ne devrait pas y
avoir de stars après le système marche
comme il marche et il ya évidemment des
idiots qui sont beaucoup plus grosse que
d'autres et qui drainent du public
est-ce que c'est mérité sans doute que
en partie oui parce que c'est mérité
pour des bonnes raisons liées à la
qualité d'abriter risation sont pas
toujours après en nous et on peut en
fait ce qui nous plaît esquivé 100 m
important que chacun de vos domaines que
on estime que ce qu'on fait mais la très
loin s'intéressent séduire les diables
lautier bureau que nous et c'est mérité
sinon on fasse de fait si on pensait
qu'il fallait faire ce qu'il veut donc
voilà si je serai correct que lui s'est
lâché la tête on top 2
il me semble qu'il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui conclut on peut considérer
comme des stars qui en fait ce sont
surtout des référents parce que ce soit
c'était les premiers à ouvrir la voie et
qui du coup ont un statut parce qu'ils
ont ils ont ouvert le milieu mais y en a
d'autres qui vraiment je pense rayonne
de par leur qualité
moi je pense pour la géopolitique c'est
pas sur youtube c'était donc l'émission
le dessous des cartes qui étaient tenus
par jean christophe victor et lui
inconditionnellement tout le monde le
reconnaissait comme étant un expert du
sujet parce qu il ya d une expertise que
beaucoup n'avaient pas et donc lui on
peut je préfère il se considère
absolument pas je pense comme une star
ou s'il n'était pas du tout dans ce
modèle là mais il dégageait un charisme
de pain ses connaissances je pense que
oui il avait une réputation que tout le
monde lui reconnaissait implicitement
mais clairement et à ce niveau là ça me
fait aussi penser à jean françois zygel
en musique qui équipent arrêt
exceptionnel qui si on devait considérer
une star de musicologie ça serait lui
mais là la grosse différence avec en
dehors du fait que ce soit pas sur
youtube il ya élargissons le
élargissions d'attention au domaine de
la vulgarisation ses stars lassé des
personnes qui travaillaient pas seul
sait les personnes qui travaillaient en
constamment en se faisant appel à des
experts véritablement pointures de même
spécifique détiennent pas mais parce
qu'elle notions en sciences dont il faut
bien avoir conscience et que le concept
d' expertise c'est hyper pointu on a
atteint un point d'un point un point de
la connaissance humaine
actuellement ou un biologiste peut pas
être au courant de 100% de la biologie
un physicien ne pas être au courant de
100% de la physique et même un historien
de mettre au courant qu'ils font pour
cent ans d'histoire
je dire un historien poser une question
neuf fois sur dix qui va vous répondre
et pas matérielles
c'est pratique mais c'est vrai mais
c'est complètement vrai c'est tellement
difficile de tout savoir sur un domaine
et donc ces personnes là qui sont
véritablement des stars de leur domaine
souvent c'était des personnes qui
avaient accès à pia pia d'accès à
d'autres personnes véritablement elle
était hyper pointu et l'inde est l'un
des soucis qu'on a sur youtube c'est
qu'il n'ya pas toujours accès à ça avec
certaines initiatives comme comme ideo
science
les collectifs conscience et fait des
sciences etc etc on a plus en plus moyen
d'avoir accès à ça d'avoir accès à des
spécialistes qui vont faire que les
vidéos elles vont être relu
on n'a pas dû bien vidéo est maintenant
ou et on peut se dire que véritablement
là le sur le plan de la rigueur
scientifique
je fais tout ce qui concerne la
technique vidéo c'est un domaine on peut
se dire que la notoriété les mérites et
tout le monde ne le fait pas on n'est
pas ici pour lâcher des noms c'est pas
le sait pas le concept mais mais il ya
des stars et la plupart d'entre elles se
regardent vraiment bien des vidéos on se
rend compte qu'elle soit on va les
univers des autres qu'elles renvoient
vers des sources qui sont véritablement
des gages de qualité
les sourds les sources est hyper
important et c'est ça qui va faire la
qualité scientifique souvent d'un
vidéaste et jeu j'en passe la parole à
mon adaptation
[Applaudissements]
oui c'est bien conservé est-ce qu'un
cette difficulté d'avoir accès à des
experts
quand on fait comme youtube heures parce
que je sais justement pas on va en faire
plus que ce que ça vient pas juste d'un
problème de légitimité du média encore
pour l'instant même si c'est en train de
se résorber
parce que c'est pas juste genre dur
d'aller voir des experts en disant il
veut faire une vidéo
elle va peut-être être vu par dix mille
personnes
est ce que ça vaut bien le car la télé
des garants d'un certain anonymat
enfin vous comprenez action là c'est
pour ça que parler des sources aussi
parce que même s'il n'a pas accès aux
personnes d'accès aux sources qui vont
être des sources de plus ou moins bonne
qualité et à une personne de tout à fait
tout à fait bien travailler tout seul
être suffisamment rigoureuse pour faire
des prêts du contenu qui est juste
ahurissant
tu prends un dirty vidéo jdc première
vidéo
la qualité et la rigueur scientifique
était là parce que mais qu'il a une
formation de biologiste et il sait où
trouver les informations il sait quelles
sont les bonnes sources
mais en plus c'est beau en plus il
faudrait donc dans quoi elle a aussi
l'avantagé d'un expert c'était de faire
il sait où sont les bonnes sources et
surtout ça il sait où sont les bonnes
sources et il sait comment travailler
pour différence entre un expert et un
profond changement a complètement roulé
dessus c'est que en géopolitique le
poème c'est qu'à chaque fois on fait
pour chaque sujet on recoupe énormément
de disciplines différentes et si par
exemple un jour on fait un sujet sur la
mer
on a besoin de quelqu'un qui est
spécialiste des océans à tel endroit
puis juste après un mec est calée sur le
droit international humanitaire puis
après lendemain un tissu calé sur
l'immigration on peut pas une seule
personne peut pas avoir toutes ses
connaissances je pense qu'au public en a
pleinement conscience et qu'on fait on
recoupe des connaissances qui montre des
années des années de fin d'engagement de
connaissance et donc du coup ce procès
je rejoins veulent être sur l'importance
des sources et qu'en fait c'est comme ça
qu'on montre on dit je peux pas avoir
rencontré ces personnes là qui travaille
sur ces sujets en revanche j'ai lu tous
les rapports qu'ont publié et l'onu sur
ce sujet et son machin et ça c'est notre
gars on va dire de c'est un peu comme si
en gros j'étais les deux cas leurs
portes et que j'aurais posé les
questions en dix mètres des jeux
j'ajoute que l'une des grosses
difficultés quand on fait de la
vulgarisation scientifique c'est que
tout ça ça prend du temps c'est hyper
long de produire du contenu de qualité
et rigoureux et malheureusement le
succès ça se fait aussi
en étant dès à présent c'est pas pour
rien si l'échelle qui fonctionne le
mieux sur internet et les chaînes s'y
produisent énormément de contenu hyper
régulier et perd souvent dans tous les
jours je joue toujours les gens voilà
les ronrons on a tous dans nos cartons
des trucs comme ça mondial et je vais
tourner tout ça pendant une semaine et a
prévu toute la sortir une par jour ça me
rappelle un truc ça me rappelle un truc
aussi qu'il écrit depuis un an ayant
restriction y en a qui le font et il
faut avoir le teint je suivais cet arrêt
gâteau 500 secousses et du coup en ce
qui concerne justement la vulgarisation
sur internet c'est aussi pour ça qu'il
ya c'est peut-être aussi pour ça qu'il
ya moins de grosses stars que dans
d'autres domaines comme le gaming ou le
podcast tu n'auras pas le micro pour
dire ça donc ouais des stars y en a mais
c'est un peu plus compliqué parce que le
star system et pas vraiment très très
adapté les réseaux sociaux réponse ok
pour revenir à ta question sur est ce
que c est compliqué ce que c'est
difficile d'aller voir un expert et lui
demander tout ça je les fais je suis
encore une toute petite chaîne mais au
départ j'étais vraiment minuscule moins
de 1000 abonnés et j'y suis allé au
culot c'était une émission que je
lançais en plus une série où je voulais
faire des reportages dans des labos est
allé voir la dernière public qui venait
de sortir d'un tel sujet les voir le
chercheur qui avait fait ça et il
interviewait tout simplement et donc j'y
suis allé au culot en interviewant
balleux le thésard d'un des plus grands
neuroscientifique en france qui parle
dans les médias et tous et il m'a dit ok
on fait ça et du coup il m'a reçue il va
aussi bien reçu que confère d'autres
gens quand j'étais blogueuse ou alors
quand je parle en tant que journaliste
parce que à côté je suis un peu
journalistes au débat est donc vraiment
il n'ya aucune différence du point de
vue des chercheurs à qui je m'adresse
et ça c'est hyper cool je vais mais est
ce que ton passé de journaliste fait pas
que déjà une forme de légitimité
mais ce que ton passé de thann est ce
que ton passé de journaliste fait pas
déjà que tu as une forme de légitimité
quand tu vas aller voir et au delà de
juste les tickets de journalistes la
manière dont tu vas l'approché de rap
est une expérience que quelqu'un qui a
passé background là derrière va barbares
aussi j'ai vu dominant traces mènent
alors juste pour préciser je suis c'est
pas mon passé de journaliste parce que
je suis encore en pole mais
effectivement ça pourrait jouer mais là
vraiment le déclic kia quand ils me
disent oui c'est juste un échange par
mail ou jeudi je me présente en tant que
tu buzz même pas en tant que journaliste
donc justement jeu j'essaye un peu pour
voir la réaction des gens et franchement
je suis agréablement surpris à chaque
fois je vous invite d'ailleurs vidéaste
aller directement contacté des gens
parce que c'est cool tu voulais prendre
la parole c'est dommage la censure la
censure sur internet ici nous on essaie
on a on a fait le constat et ces mêmes
courses à café gérald bronner dans la
des crédules
c'est qu'il ya un problème de confiance
les gens savent pas à qui faire
confiance et c qui manquent
c'est en allant de la recherche avec des
gens qui savent une chose et on a le
peuple des gens qui croient des choses
et qui s'imaginent qu'ils savent des
choses et qu'ils soient des jeunes eux
mais pas durant les mêmes et pétrole est
bonne et il manque un média qui fit près
rien qui rend intelligible et
compréhensible que ce que pour les
hindous sikhs qui rend intelligible et
question que se posent les gens
fondation se sont posés de questions aux
communes en recul en 10 ans alors ça va
être ensuite et j'articule si je peux et
nous implorons le mandat de d'être là et
on essaie d'avoir deux émissions des
scientifiques qui viennent parler et qui
viennent articulé
correctement sites mais le mot quota de
youtube et des sources
il y avait déjà plusieurs fois sur est
ce que c'est important mais des sources
sur les vidéos oui c'est important pour
que ces importantes parce que on ne peut
pas demander aux gens de savoir
distinguer une vidéo de qualité des
dinos de merdique puisque puisque
justement on est là pour le rap pour
leur donner les clés pour les distinguer
non ici on exige le visage d'emblée
distinguer le bon du mauvais barreau
tentera de vous dire c'est parce qu'ils
savent déjà tout donc ce n'est pas un
argument et ceux qui l'utilisent devrait
arrêter d'utiliser ses actions et non
mais bon instinct et et en termes de
source
quand on regarde les les des articles de
vulgarisation qu'on a sur son honnête et
parfois même dans les magazines et ce
produit sur le net et ça peut même être
des articles de commandes de la
recherche ou ou s'en servir et vous
parle d'une publication
les chercheurs de tels pays en fait elle
est couverte ont d'abord l'article
on n'a pas le lien vers l'article
comment ça se fait vous l'avez lu et
c'est agaçant l'année on devrait
toujours pouvoir en un clic avoir accès
à l'article de recherche de les écrire
même si l'anglais des gens ont droit de
voir où est ce que c'est cet été par qui
quand comment ça c'est que ce ne soit
pas un réflexe
donc ça leur coûte rien je ne comprends
pas pourquoi c'est pas fait et c'est
leur métier des journalistes payés nous
mais nous on est amateur et ont offert
un jour bien d'accord oui
le truc aussi c'est qu'il ya la guerre
de venir lire un article scientifique
c'est parce c'est pas simple et il faut
se former à la lecture d'articles
scientifiques sa mort ici à chaque fois
que je rencontre en musicologie en
général on n'a jamais appris à lire un
article scientifique avait appris à lire
des articles scientifiques en forme en
moi même et en fréquentant en
fréquentant des des gens qui eux étaient
étaient habitués à ça et le fait que les
gens et que certaines personnes du mal à
lire des articles scientifiques ça fait
des catastrophes
l'effet mozart qui est l'une des plus
grandes supercheries de de cette
superpole encore plus vague que la
musicothérapie séné à cause d'un article
manu
non il ya de bonnes choses en musique au
théâtre mais beaucoup moins que beaucoup
moins que ce qu'on pense à la basse et
un article mais tellement de l'effet
mozart c'est l'effet mozart c'est ça
voudrait quand on écoute de la musique
classique a fortiori du mozart c'est
encore mieux
on augmente ses performances cognitives
en mathématiques et on est et on devient
plus intelligents les vaches aussi les
vaches m
nos âmes par toujours est il que à la
base ça ça vient d'un papier qui est
hyper sérieux et qui est qui qui dit
juste que quand on fait entendre à des
personnes qui aiment une musique en
l'occurrence du mozart elles sont
elles sont apaisées et en conséquence de
sa dans dé bonnes dispositions cognitive
pour réfléchir c'est tout et ça ça a été
extrapolée par des gens qui en bavent
donc l'article en écouter du mozart
ça rend plus intégré c'est un bon titre
le journal
oui voilà non mais ces titres les titres
souvent ça fonctionne comme ça dans
beaucoup truc journalisme et c'est
dommage
qu'est ce qui dit il ya un truc pour la
vulgarisation pour rebondir sur ça c'est
que en géopolitique vous dit par exemple
qu'il faut citer la source quand on dit
un truc
sauf qu'en géopolitique on va te citer
un article de journal
mais d'un pays qui est soumis à des
enjeux d'un pays et si tu as un russe
j'en sais rien je pense je pense que
dans ma tête est un exemple entre les
américains et les russes mais si tu as
un syrien qui va sortir son article de
journal à lui qui a suivi sa source
tu auras l'opposé et donc c'est là en
fait tout s'est extrêmement délicat sur
les jeux politiques c'est que tout le
temps dans la nuance
parce que la ta source tu peux la
prendre trois comme extrêmement
convaincu qui dit pas si c'est eux qui
l'ont dit je le prends pour content et
du coup je le balance à mes abonnés si
tu as vingt mille personnes qui
regardent ça et que en fait ça se trouve
ils vont croire je veux dire ils vont
prendre pour comptant alors ça se trouve
cit avait nuancé son propos en disant
que bâle journal en face il a une autre
vérité
bah du coup ça rajoute une difficulté
sur le sur l'écriture du script sur la
nuance donc là après on aille dans un
débat plus large qui est le les médias
qui est les sources et tout le monde en
parle après c'était pour rebondir sur le
fait de citer les sources
j'ai par rapport à ça le simple fait de
dire cette information là elle provient
de telles sources
c'est un mot gentil - te poser la
question quelle est la source et de voir
quelle peut être biaisé mais qui peut s
ou encore dix ans quand tu ne dis pas
que les la source terroristes à chaud
c'est toi donc si tu veux pas que engagé
sa crédibilité at war il m'accuse l'info
elle vient de là il peut parler des
questions justement en parlant de
sources 1
donc les sauces permettent d'avoir un
peu d'objets d'avoir de l'objectivité
sur les vidéos est-ce qu'il ya d'autres
moyens pour les personnes qui vient de
voir nos vidéos ou d'autres vidéos de
détruire de l'objectivité de cette
vulgarisation scientifique autre que la
source d'être sûr jamais tout est
toujours un peu après est ce qu'il ya un
thème de l'étude le fait d'inviter on
doit avoir la sauce mon repos car l'on
invité un expert des cabas il faut avoir
confiance dans l'expert comme on peut
avoir un sens dans un expert c'est pas
un expert c'est quelqu'un qui a connu
experts par les autres experts donc
c'est un peu limité mais on n'a pas vu
un communiqué donc et on pourra jamais
vous assurer que ce qu'on dira on
devrait la mener en débat il ya un truc
qui à l'erc a l'air un peu con comme ça
mais faut vraiment regarder si la
personne est capable de se remettre en
question et de s'interroger de revenir
sur ce qu'elle a dit voir si si dans les
commentaires le vidéaste va dire oui
effectivement ça là dessus j'aurais pu
dire comme ça et c'est dans les
discussions et toujours des trucs comme
ça les commentaires je jeu y en a à peu
près toutes les vidéos de vulgarisation
des discussions dans les commentaires de
gens là faut voir cette vidéo ce qui est
capable de se remettre en question un
truc encore plus important et ça ça a
l'air vraiment ça va très content quand
j'ai compris ça le jeu sur les points
qu'elle aime beaucoup de choses vraiment
chérir les gens qui osent dire je ne
sais pas ce que c'est hyper difficile
c'est hyper difficile d'admettre la
nette de dieu je ne sais pas de
l'accepter
le bourdon une personne qui vous qui ose
vous dire je ne sais pas là vous pourrez
vous dire que quand elle dit je sais
c'est qu'elle a vraiment réfléchi sur un
truc et que c'est injuste quelque chose
qu'elle balance comme ça pour rebondir à
ça justement il ya des lettres des
sciences vous c'est plus facile
d'affirmer quelque chose parce qu'on a
pu le vérifier c'est prouvé ses tarifs y
ait autant garder des choses on dit
c'est à ce moment là ce qu'on pense est
vrai va et donc du coup par exemple je
pense à hugo décrypte ce qui fait lui
fait de la vulgarisation pas tendre la
vulgarisation ce que du journalisme
politique qui fait sur youtube et il dit
enfin je trouve qu'il a une pédagogie
kepone c'est qu'il fait comme les vrais
journalistes devraient faire c'est à
dire que quand il se passe quelque chose
et qu'on vient de l'apprendre midi enfin
il met toujours du conditionnel dont on
pourrait penser que c'est ça mais aucun
moment il ya une affirmation et c'est
comme ça qu'il faut faire à mon goût de
ce que tu dis c'est valable pour tous en
général même des sciences on n'est
jamais sûr de rien on est juste sur de
quelque chose jusqu'à preuve du
contraire c'est toujours une histoire de
probabilité c'est ce qui est le plus
probable de d'être en ce moment enfin
c'est pareil en fait même en sciences
quand vous regardez les publications la
plupart du temps ils utilisent le
conditionnel et après c'est juste la
retranscription dans les médias fin
certains médias est comme ça qu'ils
bouffent le conditionnel et font font
écouter d
dubos ardalh quoi et justement le fait
quand on se place en tant que vidéaste
et commence par là on a parlé des
personnes sur des sujets comme ça il
faut avoir une certaine éthique dans le
sens où je vois des personnes qui
parlent de géopolitique et qui sur des
sujets où effectivement n'y a pas
forcément de réponses vont essayer de
combler le fait qu'ils ne savent pas par
part des choses qui sont pas vraiment
bourré et on peut vite se complaire dans
le fait que de peu de peur de perdre la
face face à des personnes en disant
qu'on ne sait pas on balance des choses
qui parfois sont faussés au contraire là
ça peut empirer voire même avoir des
conséquences un peu car ça dépend des
matières mais ça peut avoir sur
l'immigration je pense ça peut déchaîner
les tensions alors que cette
désinformation qui peuvent ne même pas
de vérifier la commune une déontologie à
bord d'ailleurs c'est très bon
l'anthologie le mot du jour juste ça n'a
pas directement à bord mais ça me
rappelle une discussion que j'ai eue
avec un ami ou en fait je pense que
cette tendance qu'on ait du mal à dire
je sais pas ça nous vient peut-être de
donc c'est tellement complètement le
soir je m'arrête là sans se renverser le
vrai psychologie c'est ce que les gens
aimaient les gens assuré que tout le
temps qu il faut un relais offerts soit
rassuré mouassa discours qui m'a fait
part à une expérience personnelle parce
que c'est bien un truc que je n'étais
absolument entendre cette grande étape à
pau sans toi pourquoi parce que je
quelqu'un qui suit justement du genre à
ne pas arriver avec une restauration
c'est ça la vérité à ce jeu c est que
maintenant je n'ai fait que ceux qui
justement de si je ne sais pas eu de
l'imposer at on assuré au feu rouge pas
forcément et tampico mais c'est vrai
qu'on explique souvent je connaissais
pas des experts il explique ça s'est un
peu trop tôt autour de nous lisa bas les
gens aiment bien les gens assuré
ça inspire confiance des gens assuré il
faut contrer la confiance qu'on maîtrise
et donc du coup de gens sont tout le
temps des troubles
exactement politique de personnes qu'il
affirme avoir forcément mais ça me plaît
mais normalement c'est une philosophie
justement de préférer mais comme vous
l'êtes devrait continuer ça des gens qui
se ment se montrent plus réservés en je
pense que voilà plutôt des gens qui
affirment hier encore quelqu'un d'être
ici ma came de liège était au nord de
bruxelles
mais il a fait comme ça j'ai prouvé
contraire rien même prix de toute façon
le la position de la table-ronde par l
époque du spectateur elle doit être de
tout et même dans les gens en qui on est
censé avoir confiance je veux dire une
affirmation je pense que une démarche de
spectateurs ça c'est de dire c'est
l'affirmation de cette personne avec le
bagage qu'elle a écrite à céline vérité
absolue ça pourrait être potentiellement
une vérité absolue
ça dépend de la légitimité de la
personne accessoires complètement il ya
malheureusement qu'on peut pas prendre
toutes les précautions de langage qui
s'imposerait si on voulait être
véritablement rigoureux parce que ça
alourdirait considérablement le propos
ce serait se serait dégueulasse si on
devait terminer toutes nos phrases par
jusqu'à preuve du contraire ou par un
bas il semblerait que habitable c'est
pas possible
ce serait un vix table jusqu'à preuve du
contraire tout à fait
et puis en ce qui concerne le fait de
faire confiance on n'a pas trop
développé cet expert et où on a bien
insisté sur le fait que la science que
la science s'est pas véritablement des
autorités mais à un moment où on sait de
reconnaître widow kills ces autorités en
biologie de la seule raison pour
laquelle il fait autorité en biologie
c'est parce que le mec est justement au
courant de l'état de l'art au courant du
consensus
et quand il parle il parle pas de ces
travaux à lui il parle de l'état de la
générale de la biologie c'est pour ça
qu'on peut lui faire confiance
ce qui l'est c'est plus un porte-parole
qu'autre chose en définitive et c'est là
que ça devient quelqu'un d'intéressant
apprête à des experts prix nobel qui
tourne mal et qui parle de la mémoire de
l'eau ce genre de choses c'est l'italie
oui mais pas bon temps quand on ignore
si les prix nobel sont des gens qui
vieillissent mal ou juste des vieux
qu'on écoute alors cause dans les
écoutes par fait partie décrit les
calories mais selon les écoutes comment
saga tout y est donc c'est comment on
n'a pas un gros échantillons se révèle
en lecture de mesurer l'effet bientôt
autant finir par savoir est ce que mes
nouvelles rancourt bien des titres
journal c'est peut-être une belle
rencontre ou pas mais bon il faudra me
dire oui je sais pas du tout ce que
voulait dire je le micro dans la main je
suis content mais je garde devant la
parole à part ces deux terroristes à qui
on a une question font donc par rapport
aux sujets donc un tournant dans la
vulgarisation
je trouvais qu'ils avaient deux éléments
clés vous avez sorti la déontologie et
les sources
justement qu'est-ce que vous comptez
juste en justement vous mettre en oeuvre
par rapport à cette technologie et ses
sources
comme pratique pour rendre ces deux
termes beaucoup plus on va dire prégnant
que ce qui ne sont peut-être dans ce
qu'on peut appeler des médias classiques
de la publication scientifique etc
on peut frapper les gens qui le font pas
j'ai mieux on peut faire des guides déjà
pour montrer aux gens à quoi faire
attention par un article elle est bien
j'avais fait un article de blog où
j'avais interviewé le mandat que si
présent justement pour dit aux gens qui
regardent des vidéos à quoi faire
attention pour connaître sa qualité et
sa crédibilité
donc il ya différents indices il ya la
présence de source si elles sont
indiquées déjà la qualité des sources
aussi savoir si je sais pas s'il ya des
commentaires allaient regarder un peu ce
qu'ils en disent ce genre de chose quoi
donc c'est un peu à une gymnastique
qu'il faut qu'il faut apprendre aux
joueurs
j'étais quand même essayé de dire
quelque chose d'intéressant je ne suis
pas que violence use je suis aussi à
mort il ya il ya un truc qui est
vraiment fondamental
et qu'il faut vraiment replacé au centre
de toutes ces questions là c'est le
comment dire le visionnage actif de la
vidéo il faut encourager le public à
être lui-même acteur de ses propres
mécanismes d'apprentissage des belfrage
des bobos c'est joli loire de base ou
alors voilà il ya un truc qui se fait de
plus en plus sur youtube et ça j'en suis
vraiment très très content à dire
qu'avant la vulgarisation scientifique
s'était essentiellement vulgariser les
résultats de la science y aurait là la
science on s'est rendu compte que ça etc
c'est un petit peu moins élégant mais le
sujet quand même intéressant est de plus
en plus de dix lits à des vidéastes qui
parle de méthodes scientifiques qui
explique pourquoi tel que l'essence est
valable comment on en est arrivé là
quels ont été les différents mécanismes
qui ont été mis en place par la science
pour pourra dire voilà ça on est plus
proche de la connaissance que de la
croyance et ça c'est justement
fondamental parce que ça peut permettre
au public de reprendre possession de
justement de ses propres mécanismes
d'apprentissage et se rend compte quand
on lui raconte de la merde juste lui
même d'être sceptique étudiants
c'est un petit peu suspect ce que le
candidat style en train de me raconter
je vais aller vérifier et c'est ça qui
est important
il faut il faut encourager les
spectateurs à ne pas être passifs face
aux informations qu'on leur propose
alors ça c'est du point de vue du public
qui point de vue des vidéastes il ya le
l'exemplarité et alors on a vidé aux
sciences telle était équipé d'élection
des terres donc dédié tout ce qu'il faut
en cours à tout ce qui peut encourager
les fidèles s'affairent bien donc il ya
une brillante est fait obligation il ya
plein de mauvaises manières des fêtes de
la vulgarisation et comme initiative on
est en contact avec vidéo science avec
le ministère de l'enseignement de la
recherche pour essayer de créer un prix
de la vulgarisation numérique
ils ont vaincu raison que c'est génial
et il répond plus aux emails alors
relancé ma chérie tu est pas
c est donc dans l'idée ce serait de que
les que le monde de la recherche avec
nous confondre un jury et que rien à
double ou reconnaître à la saq cette
vidéo là où cette série de vidéos cette
chaîne fait un travail qui est
remarquable dandonneau son approche et c
est le fait de mettre en avant c'est pas
pour dire ah le ministère approuvent
ça c'est ce qu'on voit pas ce que le
monde de la recherche valide
ça c'est comme ça qu'ils veulent que
lors que le culot re leur travail soit
mis à la naissance du public et quand
les plus gardés d'heure verront que
c'est et de vidéos là est mis en avant
bah comme il veut le faire bien général
ils auront les marqueurs gars assez bien
en game là et ça facilitera aussi fait
que ceux qui suivent le bon modèle
or en plus facilement accès aux
chercheurs et du coup il ya une fuite
est plus importante entremont de la
recherche et le monde de ce qui manque
un peu ça que quand on est une tube
heures avant le départ mais quand elle
c'est le tube il ya un manque de
légitimité en ont les qui nous pour pour
aller voir des chercheurs c'est une
vraie question alors ça c'est plutôt
bien
nous on a un documentaire on a fait le
tour de france des chercheurs serein sur
domaine des croyances la plupart nous
ont répondu oui mais c'est pas garanti
quoique que bonjour sur la tronche en
biais ouais moi je fais la belle
personne
un rouge profond pour rien vous cacher
j'ai eu un gros problème de légitimité
au début je me suis dit j'ai 25 ans
enfin j'avais 25 ans à l'époque je me
lance pour faire une chaîne de
géopolitique
quand je vois des conférences de
géopolitique la moyenne d'âge âgé de 70
ans et je me suis dit est-ce que je vais
être crédible est ce que je suis
illégitime est ce que je vais même si
j'ai eu des expériences à l'étranger est
ce que je peux parler de ces choses-là
est-ce que est donc en fait j'ai pas
fais deux
j'ai passé comme vous qui lâchent rien
de guide pour expliquer comment enfin
comment appréhender ces sujets là est
par contre quelque chose que j'aime
beaucoup faire c'est toujours contre
balancer nuancée des choses qu'on nous
qui nous paraissent complètement acquise
par exemple un sujet qui je trouve part
lancé aux états unis on n'arrête pas de
dire que la menace principale poids des
états unis c'est les musulmans et
notamment les islamistes alors que en
termes de morts c'est l'extrême droite
américaine qui est beaucoup plus
dangereuse pour l'état et ce genre de
choses là en fait juste en les
contrebalançant et a pas forcément
besoin de guide pour leur dire qu'il
faut mais en fait naturellement les gens
disent ah ouais donc en fait faut pas
prendre pour acquis tout ce qui nous est
dit parce que quand on des zooms un peu
bas parfois on découvre qu'il ya des
rapports de force qui sont pas
équitables ou des choses qu'on prenait
pour normal qu'ils ne sont pas donc
c'est plutôt ça moi ma manière de faire
d'autant que j'ai absolument pas la
prétention d'avoir la pédagogique avec
enfin qu'on d'autres chaînes notamment
geopolitis qui est une émission suisse
de géopolitique ou le dessous des cartes
c'est que des chercheurs et ont rejoint
sujet tout à l'heure c'est des
chercheurs qui se communique entre sur
les différents sujets sur lesquels ils
travaillent comme je suis tout seul à te
faire tout bien sûr je n'ai pas la
prétention d'avoir une déontologie à ce
qu'on la pousse et donc j'essaie plus de
de nuancer les propos est de faire
réfléchir les gens par eux mêmes sur sur
ça dans les faits une fact aux
etats-unis et pas des gens qui sont
plupart des attaques terroristes sont
dans le doute les gens qui sont tués par
leurs enfants qui tourne sur une arme à
feu guy kastler par an dont 20
d'étrangers voilà on est volé c'est
marrant les gens meurent est une autre
question
non alors il ya des filles à serment
d'accident grave y'a pas toi y'a un truc
aussi de qu'il faut faire et c'est un
réflexe hyper difficile parce qu'on a
globalement on est des [ __ ] des
niveaux sociaux de merde
la table est grave les tapas 2010 est
belle on est des [ __ ] d'animaux
sociaux de merde et du coup on a
tendance à valoriser la personnalité là
où il faudrait valises et la vanité la
production enfin valoriser la production
je prends les docks et tout à l'heure
voilà donc il s'est dit prêt à respecter
pas parce que ces doctrines c'est qu'il
est ce qu'il est super soirée avec son
accent anglais et quand il dit ça rien
de cette fois que ce patch j'adore ce
mec mais mais pour autant le mec s'il
est véritablement respecter c'est parce
qu'il a fait masse et masse et masse
d'articles de production scientifique
qui ont été qui ont été de qualité
incroyable donc faut savoir de temps en
temps prendre un petit peu de recul
et encourager le crépuscule des idoles
pour permettre l'aube des idées il faut
puisque les futurs maîtres l'aube des
idées il faut encourager le crépuscule
des idoles pour encourager l'obésité m
un serment dax tu m'avais dit j'aurais
été plus classe de piano de merde alors
justement parle énormément des
recherches des sources est un peu
préparé le sujet du coup j'ai préparé
aussi mon sujet pour le débat donc j'ai
un peu regardé jeu vidéo le panel votre
historique est par contre je me souviens
vraiment des vidéos qu'on avait en cours
de sciences de géopolitique à l'école où
c'étaient des vieux et vieilles
cassettes de c'est pas sorcier tout
pourri ou alors une cassette de
dissection de grenouilles est ce que
vous avez est-ce que mais en rien dans
vos vidéos
la vulgarisation passe tellement bien et
pour un public aussi d'adolescents d'un
niveau secondaire non glissé au collège
est-ce que vous avez déjà eu des
demandes des cols ou des profs ou ne fut
ce qu'on vous notifie qu'on utilise aux
vidéos dans un cadre pédagogique
je pense que ce qui a changé c'est que
par exemple c'est pas sorcier malgré le
fait que ce soit vraiment génialissime
n'y a rien à dire dessus c'est des
adultes qui font ça pour des enfants ou
des jeunes alors que sur youtube c'est
des jeunes qui font ça pour des jeunes
donc du coup sur la forme on a conçu une
accroche qui qui plaît beaucoup plus
d'autant que effectivement quand je
disais que c'est très artistique chez
pas si le spectateur sent rang mais
quand on crée une vidéo et des moments
on se sent un peu artiste parce qu'on
mon cher un peu la musique on gère tout
ça je veux dire c'est une impression
vraiment de créer quelque chose et donc
du coup je pense qu'on touche les jeunes
de manière beaucoup plus direct que des
émissions de détection de grenouille je
pense que dirty biology toucher les
jeunes facilement que que ça par exemple
et il est plus beau aimer du coup pour
les pour les membres madge envoyer des
messages comme quoi les quelques
épisodes ont été passées en cours et ça
ça me fait vraiment plaisir
et sinon après on parle aussi des
institutions justes et après ministère
de la défense qui je fais une vidéo en
ce moment là sur les conflits actuels et
donc du coup hausse a rejoint le mans du
marais justement c'est là où c'est très
nouveau aussi c'est qu'ils se sont
rendus compte qu'ils vont grandir c'est
un épisode en fait qui est qui et
interactif donc c'est tous les abonnés
qui m'ont posé leurs questions sur le
sujet et je les ai vaut 30 injuste
regrouper mais j'ai mis des questions
hyper difficile à répondre je leur
envoyais ils les ont laissées ils m'ont
dit on veut répondre à ce genre de
questions on n'a jamais pu le faire
parce que votre foi ça marchait pas mais
de dire qu'un militaire 10 passes caméra
ce que ça fait tuer qu'ils soient
obligés à près de partir dans des
cellules pour psychologique ou de savoir
ce que c'est qu'une attaques par drones
dans un pays et où ils ont envie de se
positionner sur le sujet donc au
contraire je fonctionne à la pollution
et il s'adapte aussi à notre niveau où
on a envie de parler de tout sans
complexe ça s'est vraiment bien je
trouve donc chant c'est pour ça que j'ai
accepté aussi c'est que je me suis dit
que j'avais peut-être apporter des vins
ou du moins l'épisode à lui apporter des
réponses que on n'était pas l'habitude
de voir
donc c'est la seule institution pour
moment qui me fait confiance mais
j'espère que ça continuera
parti avec tout mon respect pour leo
judas est très beau aussi un way we un
écho très régulier
est il alors nous on arrêtera venu dans
un lycée à lille les an plus tôt on
reçoit des mails de gens qui disent
qu'ils sont profs et qu'il y met des
extraits de vidéos donc ça va ça pousse
donc visiblement ça sert on en a pas un
format forcément avant l'intérêt de deux
heures que pas du tout utilisable dedans
on a une vidéo canon qui font tourner
d'ici quinze minutes aussi une séquence
de jeu est un peu long donc c'est le
vendais des formes avancées booste le
format il a duré qui fait que ça peut
être un matériel exploitable de laurent
classe parce que il faut que l'europe
c'est introduire et qu'après il fallait
s'y est bien celui de kido 40 minutes ça
va être un peu compliqué de débriefer
après mais on n'est pas prof papa d'un
petit mais on peut être auxiliaire
parfois et ça c'est cool
du coup non je n'ai pas eu cette chance
notamment des vidéos diffusées canton et
collèges et lycées je suis très triste
si vous avez un collège le jour où je
suis prof promis jeudi je puisse tenter
les achats d'or mais du coup je vais
juste rebondir sur un truc que gildas
dit le fait ce soit des jeunes qu'ils
fassent des vidéos pour les jeunes c'est
peut-être aussi ça qui explique le
succès de youtube parce que on fait ce
qui nous plaît alors que si vous prenez
à la télé par exemple des vieux qui font
des trucs pour les jeunes il pense faire
un truc qui plaît aux jeunes et des fois
ça fait pas très branché
c'est un peu la grande différence je
trouve entre la télé youtube c'est que
vraiment on fait des trucs qui nous
plaît justement pour revenir sur ses pas
sorcier qui a fait un grosse campagne de
financement participatif pour rebondir
et procréer esprit sorcier sur internet
je pense que ça aurait pu être plus
opportun justement qui s'accompagne de
beaucoup plus de jeunes parce que j'ai
l'impression que ils sont dit on est sur
youtube ont fait un truc pour les jeunes
mais c'est eux qui ont calqué leur
vision du futur donc du coup ça fait
parfois des décors avec un peu comme on
imaginer le futur il ya 20 ans on
faisait les voitures qu'il volait tout
c'est un petit peu comme ça donc si
petits qu'ils avaient peut-être plus
enfin il s'est peut-être plus
accompagnés de jeunes le résultat aurait
peut-être est-elle encore plus s'adapter
jamais la contrôler a fait un petit film
avec avec la mac je me permets juste de
dire un truc parce que du coup je
connais les gens qui travaillent
d'esprit sorcier est ce que cette époque
est en fait l'équipe pib rejoindre au
contraire c'est juste après dés puis tu
as entendu un autre aussi je n'ai même
oui je pense que c'est plutôt justement
la direction qui choisit tout ça est
donc peut-être effectivement comme tu
disais vous êtes tout à l'heure qu'ils
ont juste pas pris le tournant youtube
comme il fallait et encore moi je trouve
que j'aime bien ce qu'ils font c'est
juste que les dossiers sont peut-être un
peu long des fois mais je trouve que
franchement comparer c'est pas sorcier
c'est cool quoi le truc qui a vraiment
qui a vraiment fait qu'ils aient
beaucoup de monde aussi c'était le prix
des épisodes quand ils ont annoncé
qu'ils ont lancé un descendant synchro
funding qui a quand même rapporter pas
mal d'argent et du coup avec ce crâne
league
tout le monde s'est dit on va voir la
masse d'épisodes super bien c'est trop
cool et ils ont annoncé le camping est
finie on a quand on met quatre épisodes
il était encore au standard télévision
dans lesquelles une émission c'est super
cher à tourner alors que voilà tous ceux
qui font de la vidéo ici savent que
c'est pas rare qu'on fasse des vidéos
qui tient un traitement c'est un petit
peu l' empire de la débrouille et là on
s'est retrouvés et détruits qui était
complètement hors de proportion et qui
était pas du tout du tout du tout
calibré pour youtube donc je pense que
le problème c'est pas tellement un
soucis de jeunesse ou même de génération
mais plus un souci de médias qui a été
incompris ils ont d'ailleurs particulier
de c'est pas sorcier peut-être aussi que
les avait soulevé il avait le poids de
ce qu'ils avaient déjà fait il pouvait
pas trop si oui alors chacon à musique
qui disait que le problème de l'esprit
sorcier c'est peut-être aussi qu'ils
avaient le poids de ce qu'ils avaient
fait auparavant et qui pouvait pas trop
se permettre de faire autre chose c'est
certain enfin je pense que c'est comme
ça que eux ils le voyaient mais on sait
très bien de notre côté que l'on
s'attendait à un renouveau sa tante est
pas la même chose
j'ai toujours pas répondu à la question
moi c'est drôle sinon ça se trouve je le
souhaite les dans dix ans on est
toujours sur youtube et qui est une
nouvelle génération qui débarque
peut-être que nous on voudra s'installer
on prendra le mode et youtube qui sera
complètement des galettes c'est normal
que ce soit une adaptation et que eux
ont fait chez pas combien d'années avec
ce modèle là donc forcément je peux
comprendre qu'il ya une difficulté de
s'adapter aux modèles très différents
ah je sais juste un petit truc a
apprécié vous emporter dans un parfait
mais ils sont pas morts ils sont bien
vivants presse d'esprit ça s'est passé
c'est fini et c'est pas sorcier je sais
pas s'ils se relancent pas parce qu'il
ya ces ressources qui y mène est visé
par ces ouais moi je prendrai quelles
histoires cyrus il me semble que c'est
je sais par à vérifier en temps de
l'histoire de répondre à la question
déjà mon bac ça t'a dit qu'on avait
c'est qu'on essaie des choses en
relation avec le ministère dont la fête
de la science vous lasser de la science
voilà c'est des choses avant la fin de
la guerre on le sait parce que c'était
super intéressant il nous donnait il
nous donnait l'opportunité d'avoir accès
à vtt gm on est très grande
infrastructure de recherche coûte dans
les dom a pu aller pour interviewer des
chercheurs des chercheurs en sciences du
climat
c'était hyper intéressant ça nous a
permis un petit peu de discuter
réchauffement climatique c'est ce qui
est drôle c'est que de base il voulait
pas trop parler du réchauffement
climatique et au final ça devrait tenir
les galets les climato sceptiques parce
qu'ils en ont beaucoup parlé mais nous
voilà et donc donc le fait est qu'on a
on a eu cette opportunité là c'était
vachement bien et moi en musicologie en
fait monsieur je gère j'ai appris par
tam tam tam est de gens mes vidéos sont
entre pam a diffusé dans des
conservatoires et des écoles de musique
ce qui en ferait pas complètement
étonnant parce que musée des 100 à
l'heure il n'y a pas beaucoup de
champions de la musicologie sur sur
internet et je pense que youtube c'est
un média qui passera avec un bon prof il
a envie d'offrir à ses élèves des choses
qui peuvent l'intéresser
parce que comment disons nous faut
vraiment insister là dessus on n'est pas
des profs on est les producteurs de
contenu simplement voilà un prof ou de
distribuer quatre collègues polycopiés à
ses élèves
si peu leur diffuser une vidéo en se
disant que ça va avoir un meilleur
impact et qui vont me retenir pour ce
que c'est tout bénef rôle comme le wifi
est précisé que c'est le titre d'une
conférence qui a lieu un peu plus tard
savait précisément là on va laisser 20
ans ont conclu
merci à tous d'être venus vous êtes des
méditations pas à la wii
youtube est un tournant pour la
vulgarisation scientifique et donc ça ça
vient de propriétés inhérentes à la tête
hors bitume on a vu aussi que du coup il
y avait 1 traverse était le fait de
rester vraiment dans le vrai dans ce
comté le plus possible en tout cas et du
coup ça ça passe par afficher ses
sources bien s'entourer tout ça est
croisé ses sources aussi c'est important
et et que l'esprit sorcier n'est pas
mort je ne sais pas voulu ajouter des
choses ou oui les deux univers il y aura
une conférence dans une heure à 14h30
qui sera sur l'enseignement et youtube
donc est-ce que youtube va remplacer les
manuels scolaires
voilà
[Applaudissements]